en la capital de la región del norte los
líderes del frente de liberación del
pueblo de tigre están a la merced del
ejército de ti el miércoles terminó el
ultimátum de 72 horas que dio el
gobierno sin que hubiese una respuesta
los líderes de tigre dejaron claro que
lucharían hasta el final en una
declaración el primer ministro etíope
dijo que le ordenó a las fuerzas
oficiales hacer el último envión sobre
la ciudad de mekler y añadió que el
ejército intentaría proteger a los
civiles pero también advirtió que no
tendrían piedad con quienes no lograran
distanciarse de los combatientes de
tigre el gobierno asegura que tanques y
soldados han rodeado la ciudad durante
los últimos tres días esperando a que
los líderes regionales se rindan la onu
dice que la situación es desesperante y
alertó que las casas en la región es
cada vez más crítica las fotos
satelitales muestran a conductores
haciendo filas por gasolina mientras los
dispensadores se secan agencias
humanitarias calculan que los combates
han desplazado a más de un millón de
personas decenas de miles huyeron de la
región de tigre y terminaron aquí en
campamentos pobremente construidos en el
borde de ciudad
solo imagina que dependes de alguien más
para todo literalmente para todo desde
tu comida y el agua potable hasta las
facilidades para ir al baño y lavar tus
manos a medida que la crisis se
profundiza la unión africana ha
intentado mediar pero sus múltiples
apuestas por improvisar un acuerdo han
sido rechazadas por el gobierno etíope